des ratés rahim directeur de recherche à
l'institut de la protection sociale
européenne
auteur de géopolitique de l'algérie aux
éditions bibliomonde bonsoir et merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
alger réclame donc toujours la
repentance de la france pour les crimes
commis durant les 132 ans de
colonisation d'algérie le contentieux
reste important mais alger a mené des
acquis d'une grande valeur morale selon
les termes employés des acquis obtenus
par l'algérie de citer notamment la
récupération des crânes en juillet de 24
combattants nationalistes tuées au début
du colonialisme pourquoi est-ce que
c'était important pour alger bonjour
d'abord je retiens une petite
rectification ip est ce c'est ainsi
qu'ils prospective sécurité en europe je
suis pas très compétent qu'on parlait
des questions sociales cette précision
est en fait c'est important pour
l'algérie c'est important pour le régime
algérien de continuer à exploiter ce
philo de la légitimité mémorielle alors
qu'on ne peut pas dire qu'ils en effet
l'un des segments de l'éducation de la
population puisque la l'histoire en
algérie est d'abord une histoire qui est
intéressé au sens où on a fait
disparaître des manuels scolaires ceux
qui ont porté une voix dissidente est ce
les crânes notamment et être une manière
pour ce régime qui est en grande
difficulté actuellement avec le l acquis
depuis deux ans manifestent au moins
deux fois par semaine c'était donc une
manière pour récupérer ce crâne et de
continuer à exploiter ce cette
légitimité issue de l'histoire et de la
guerre d'algérie mais en aucun cas issus
des urnes je crois que ça fait une
différence considérable en mars
emmanuel macron a reconnu la
responsabilité de l'armée française dans
la mort du dirigeant nationaliste alliés
wendel en 1957 c'est un autre pas de
paris vers alger selon vous oui c'est un
depuis maintenant une quinzaine d'années
on assiste à des gestes régulièrement de
la part des autorités françaises
c'est toujours insuffisant je pourrais
le comprendre
ça peut être tout à fait perceptible
mais uniquement du point de vue du
régime algérien
les algériens la population la société
algérienne
elle est passée depuis fort longtemps à
autre chose et elle a bien compris que
c'est un régime qui instrumentalisent
qui exploite cette histoire à des fins
politiques et non pas pour des vertus
pédagogiques et dans dans la perspective
de de permettre à tous les algériens
d'avoir une culture commune à propos de
leur histoire même si là encore les
convictions sont différents mais en tout
cas on ne peut pas nier que depuis le
président chirac et ceux qui lui ont
succédé
il y a eu des mots et des gestes
aujourd'hui encore l'ambassadeur de
france en algérie est allé à à sétif
déposé une gerbe devant la stèle qui
rappelle les massacres qui ont eu lieu
le 8 mai 1945
donc c'est un geste important et je
crois que l'on en attend aujourd'hui que
l'algérie puisse faire un pas vers nous
au sens où elles comprennent où elles
nous disent où elle nous livre quel est
son point de vue sur l'histoire mais une
histoire basée sur des témoignages et
des faits et non pas une histoire
exploiter alors quel parc pourrait faire
alger en direction de paris est ce que
paris de son côté pourrait aller jusqu'à
la repentance demandé par alger écoutez
ça c'est une question la question d'art
pendant c est totalement de mon point de
vue
je caricature un peu le propos est
anecdotique parce qu'on voit bien que
tous les gestes qui ont été faits depuis
maintenant 20 ans sont des gestes
symboliques forts les déclarations qui
sont venus en appui à ces gestes sont
également importants la question de la
repentance n'est pas une revendication
de ou d'un débat qui s'est posé en
france c'est là encore une
instrumentalisation du régime algérien
qui fait de la surenchère nationaliste
pour bien montrer à la population qu'il
est le gardien le garant de cette
mémoire historique
mais encore une fois je 26 tj revient
beaucoup cette histoire ne doit être
faite raconte ai transmises car partir
de faits et de témoignages et non pas à
partir de petits arrangements
merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
répondre à nos questions kader
abderrahim directeur de recherche à
l'institut prospective et sécurité de
l'europe rappelle le titre de votre
ouvrage aux éditions bibliomonde
géopolitique de l'algérie